on les compare à pierre et marie curie
les découvreurs de la radioactivité
ugur chahine et unl aimes-tu richie sans
les créateurs du premier vaccin contre
la copie dès lé fondateur du laboratoire
bio ntech à mayence en allemagne
lui en est le pdg est la directrice
médicale
ils ont tous deux une formation de
médecins ils sont spécialisés dans des
traitements contre le cancer et les
maladies graves et héréditaire dans leur
thérapie individuelle il utilise la
technologie de la rn message est une
molécule qui déclenche une réponse
immunitaire chez le patient
ils voient venir la pandémie très tôt en
janvier et mettent leur 1500 employés au
travail sans relâche sur un vaccin basé
sur cette même technologie
elle leur permet de réduire très
rapidement une quarantaine de vaccins
possible à un seul coup gorshin offre au
monde entier la production le
financement et les tests sont confiés au
géant américain pfizer avec ibeo intec
est déjà collaboré et le pdg de phase
albert bourla est d'origine grecque et
les fondateurs de biotech sont d'origine
turque
ils se connaissent bien ils sont amis
qui a dit que grecs et turcs ne
s'entendaient pas ugur fils d'ouvrier
est arrivé de turquie à l'âge de 4 ans
et 2 lem est né en allemagne d'un père
médecin d'istanbul ont dit qu'ils
n'apprécient pas trop que les médias
allemands ont davantage mis l'accent sur
leurs origines que sur leurs
réalisations
c'est une formidable histoire pour la
presse allemande dans un contexte d'
attaques parfois racistes de politiciens
contre les immigrants et c'est un
magnifique démenti puisque les enfants
de personnes étrangères des personnes
qui vivent qu'ils proviennent de
l'étranger sont un formidable facteur de
développement et de dynamisme pour
l'économie allemande
puisque il ya eu des statistiques
récentes de la banque d'investissement
d'état qui s'appelle la kfw
et qui attestent du fait que sur les 600
mille entreprises qui ont été créées en
allemagne bayer dernière il y en a une
sur quatre qui a été fondée par une
personne d'origine étrangère se sert de
ses affidés pâquis citoyens d'origine
turque qui peuvent être fiers discours
chahine mais aussi l'allemagne tous les
allemands et les gens de mayence aussi
peu à l'aise avec les médias qu pour les
questions économiques il semble
indifférent leur immense fortune qui les
place parmi les 100 plus riches
d'allemagne
pourquoi on achèterait un avion ne même
pas de voiture distille ils se déplacent
à vélo
comment ont-ils fêter ça lorsque frei
the leur a dit que leur vaccin était
efficace à 95%
le champagne n'est pas d'autres trucs
nous nous sommes assis nous nous sommes
préparés un thé puis nous avons réfléchi
à ce qui s'est passé et à ce qui va
suivre ce qui va suivre
c'est probablement une révolution dans
le monde des vaccins et de la médecine
jean-michel le prince serait du canada
montréal